[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY: Thank
you guys for coming
to watch me make cupcakes.
I would love for this to
be interactive and really
laid-back, so if anybody
has any questions
or wants me to talk
about something specific,
you could blurt it out, or you
could say, "hey," or whatever,
or use the microphone.
We're going to do two
things together today.
First, I'm going to make three
of our seven limited-edition
Valentine's Day flavors, which
you have here, which I highly
recommend getting.
Obviously, I'm Melissa
from Baked by Melissa,
and I want you to purchase
our product that I
worked so hard to create.
But also, our Valentine's
Day collection
are some of the best flavors
we've ever had before,
and it's our busiest
time of year,
and I'm just most
proud of these.
So I highly recommend them.
Also, the packaging
is beautiful.
You have this love
letter gift-box.
I'm sorry, I have to.
I'm so proud.
It's like it's my child.
Just a little fun
fact is that I used
to work with Deutsch
Advertising, which
had its office on
the 14th floor,
and my cubicle was there.
And I was fired
from my job there,
and that's ultimately
what got me baking--
or I was baking, but
starting Baked by Melissa,
so this is super
cool and full-circle,
and I'm very honored to be here.
[APPLAUSE]
And I'm pregnant.
It's not cupcakes.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
Anyway, so I'm going
to make three flavors.
The first flavor is my
absolute favorite flavor.
It's our dark chocolate cupcake.
I love dark chocolate.
I eat a piece of dark
chocolate every night
before I go to sleep.
Now I'm just going
to pop one of these.
It's so weird that we've
never done this before,
because it's so simple.
And if you've ever been curious
as to how we make the cupcakes,
now you'll see.
And you could totally
apply this at home
if you feel like stuffing
your own cupcakes.
They'll probably be
a little bit bigger
until we start selling
the pans, but in order
to stuff a cupcake, all you
have to do is put your icing
or filling in a pastry bag,
and puncture the cupcake,
and just squeeze.
It's so simple.
When we first started the
company, I'm not like oper--
now, I'm pretty
operational, but I
used to use a knife to cut
a hole in every cupcake,
and then stuff it.
And then, a few
years ago, I realized
you could just do this.
You know, they sell those
corers for the cupcakes.
This is a dark
chocolate ganache,
and this is our dark
chocolate icing.
If you happen to have "Cakes
by Melissa," my cookbook,
or get one, there's a
chocolate icing recipe.
If you switch out the Hershey's
cocoa powder for the Hershey's
dark cocoa powder, you'll
get a dark chocolate icing,
and it's so good.
Have you guys tried this one?
It was the ones topped
with mini chocolate
chips and the pink
and red nonpareils.
AUDIENCE: It's really good.
It's my favorite cupcake.
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY: It's so good.
And then, after we do
these three flavors,
the next flavor is going to
be cookies and milk, which
is a vanilla version
of cookie dough.
And it's also made with
a Chips Ahoy cookie
icing, because I just really
like dessert and snacks,
and that's how I create.
So when I was thinking about
doing a cookies and milk
flavor, I knew that it needed
to have Chips Ahoy cookies,
because when I was
growing up, that's what
cookies and milk means to me.
You know, dipping the Chips
Ahoy cookie in the milk,
and then letting the bubbles
come up until it got soggy.
Oh my god, I'm lying.
I'm not doing Chips Ahoy.
I'm not doing cookies and milk.
I'm doing salted
caramel pretzel, which I
think we call white chocolate.
SPEAKER 1: White chocolate.
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY:
White chocolate pretzel.
So this one's good too.
[LAUGHTER]
It's stuffed with
dulce de leche,
and the icing is actually--
OK, but here, it's
the perfect example.
The icing is a pretzel icing.
So I wanted to figure out a
way to do a salty, sweet type
of cupcake without
just doing something
basic like salted caramel.
And so I decided to put pretzels
in the icing and the brittle,
so this is white chocolate
mixed with ground pretzels,
and it's-- well, you tried it.
I hope you liked it.
But it's salty and
sweet, and to me, it
tastes like pretzels and
caramel, and it's amazing.
So I'm just going to finish
icing these and top them,
and then we'll do
the last flavor.
And then, after that, I
am going to make a layer
cake for you guys.
SPEAKER 1: Question over here.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk
about-- do you still come up
with all the new
flavors yourself,
or do you have a team, or--
how involved are you still
in that process?
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY:
That's a great question.
I'm very much involved
in that process.
I create and conceptualize
every new flavor and product
that we create.
I'm sorry.
I get out of breath
randomly sometimes.
It's new.
I think it's because of that.
[LAUGHTER]
So I apologize.
I met my husband the day we
opened our very first store.
It's a great, crazy story of
how we started the company.
He's part of it.
And I wound up hiring
him, and the two of us
used to ice every single cupcake
together, the first two years
that we were in business.
And now he works in the
bakery and in corporate,
and my role is president
and chief product officer.
So I create and
conceptualize everything,
but then he brings
it to production.
So we work together.
So I'll be make a pretzel
icing, and he'll be--
or this brittle, for example.
You have to be able to produce
it to make thousands of them,
so sometimes my requests
are a little silly.
But he always figures
out ways to make
them work, and
sometimes he even takes
what I've either created
once or I'm asking for,
and makes it even better.
It's a very fortunate
partnership.
The last of the three
flavors that I am making
is chocolate cookie dough.
So cookie dough and cookie
flavors, in general,
are a very popular thing for us.
Everyone loves them.
So this is a chocolate
version of cookie dough.
It is chocolate cake.
The stuffing is a chocolate
version of cookie dough,
so it has cocoa in it, and it's
salty and sweet and delicious.
It's iced with vanilla
icing, and it's
topped with chocolate
cookie dough that is here.
It kinda looks like
the poop emoji, but--
[LAUGHTER]
--there is a pink drizzle that
we put on top to make it look
like--
it works.
It's crazy.
But my pink chocolate
didn't melt so well,
so you're just going to
get the cookie topping.
And those are three of the
Valentine's Day flavors.
I don't know where my
gloves are, maybe--
well, here.
So then you literally just--
I would have put gloves on.
It's just neater and easy,
but it's not a big deal.
And that's the chocolate
cookie dough cupcake.
It gets confusing.
We have cookies and cream,
we have cookie dough,
we have chocolate cookie dough,
we have a double-cookie flavor,
which is coming back soon.
But cookies are so good,
and cookies with cake
are even more amazing.
OK.
Does anybody want a freshly
cupcake baked by Melissa?
[APPLAUSE]
OK, so that was part one.
That's just, you know, why I'm
here-- bite-sized cupcakes.
They're really amazing.
I could ice cupcakes
all day long.
I used to.
For two years, that's all I
did, was ice and bake cupcakes,
and I couldn't
have been happier.
But we grew the business,
so now I do a lot of things.
So in October, I came out
with a book that I wrote.
It's called "Cakes by
Melissa," and the reason
that I felt like I
needed to write a book
was because I had all of
these recipes in my head
that I'd been using for Baked
by Melissa all the time.
And even though you can't
make bite-sized cupcakes,
I really wanted the
reader to be able to think
the way I think and get
creative the way I create.
So I think it achieved that.
And it takes you through
my creative process
of coming up with these
random flavor profiles,
starting with a very base--
like vanilla cake,
as an example--
and then adding one
or two ingredients.
And you can make anything.
If you take your
vanilla cake base
and replace the liquid,
which is whole milk,
with strawberry puree, you
get this bomb strawberry cake.
And it's crazy, and
it's super simple.
And people always
think that baking
is crazy and really complicated,
but I don't think it is.
So the cake that I'm going
to make for you guys today
is the tie-dye cake, because
that's why we're here.
But we don't have a
ton of time together,
so the cake is already made,
and my husband made it.
He sent it to us.
So it's big, so it's on one of
our sheet pans from the bakery.
And I like to make my
layer cakes this way,
because I don't like the crust.
And obviously, in
the book, the recipe
is for a quarter-sheet
pan, because that's normal.
But you know, we got this one.
So you wouldn't have as much
scrap as I'm going to have,
so don't judge.
And I use the scrap to
decorate the cake too.
But you take six-inch or however
big you want your cake to be--
Amazon is amazing.
You can get anything
you need on Amazon,
and you don't have
to be a baker.
You can Google recipes.
You could get "Cakes by Melissa"
and use those recipes and order
everything you need, and
then just have a lot of fun.
So I actually didn't know
that these things existed
until I searched on
Amazon, because I wanted
to be able to make
cakes of all sizes
when I was recipe-testing.
So I like to punch
out my layers,
because then it's like the
whole cake is delicious.
You know?
Layer one.
Got my vanilla icing.
Does anyone know the three
ingredients in vanilla icing?
AUDIENCE: Sugar.
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY: Sugar.
AUDIENCE: Butter,
sugar, vanilla.
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY: Great.
Butter, sugar, vanilla extract.
It's so easy.
I actually added a
little bit of whole milk
to this, because when
I'm spreading on cake--
you know how it can
get really messy?
This just makes it a much
smoother consistency,
and it's much--
see?
It's so easy.
So a little icing
between each layer.
So before, again, I
wanted to write a book,
but I wasn't sure how I would
get the bit-sized cupcakes
through in this book that I
knew I couldn't give you recipes
for, because it's
impossible to bake them.
And that's when I learned
how to make cakes.
I had obviously
made cakes before,
but I had never really
put together a layer cake.
So I'm telling you--
I'm not just saying this.
Obviously, yes, I work
with my hands for a living,
and I make cupcakes, but
if I could put together
these cakes--
I'm not the neatest
person in the world--
then anyone can.
So that's layer two.
It's like making a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich.
And then more vanilla icing.
Does anyone have
any other questions?
What do you want
me to talk about?
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
that people really go crazy
for the cookie flavors?
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And so I was just
curious what metrics like that
have to do with your
flavor development.
Do you use those metrics
to figure out next flavors?
And how do you do that,
but also keep to what
you want your tastes to be?
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY:
That's a great question.
So luckily, I've found
that, for the most part--
I'm not a vanilla person.
The tie-dye cupcake is
our number-one seller.
Thank goodness it is
our signature flavor.
It makes complete sense.
It's great for our brand,
but it's not my go-to.
It's my daughter's.
She loves it.
But with that said,
for the most part,
I know when a flavor
is going to be amazing.
So the dark chocolate,
as soon as I tasted it,
I just did a happy dance, and
I couldn't stop eating it,
and it's selling
so well right now.
We obviously look at the
data, every week, actually.
Mondays are dedicated
to sales meetings
to go over the previous week.
And one of the
reports we look at
is the cupcakes and how
they sold a la carte,
because that's super helpful
for me in product development.
And I know that the Baked by
Melissa customer loves vanilla,
and chocolate, and
cookies, and stoner-type--
it's called Baked by
Melissa, so the double-cookie
is Oreo, cookie
dough, chocolate.
It's so good.
And that's what I
like, so it works.
But I'm always looking to
see what's sells the best.
Sugar cookie dough--
I have this sugar
cookie dough recipe
that I just Googled and
fell in love with, and maybe
changed a little.
But really, it's just this
standard sugar cookie dough
recipe that I was making
for my whole office,
and they loved it.
I was like, oh my god, how
could I get this in a cupcake?
And then I developed a
sugar cookie dough icing,
which is sugar cookie dough
but with an icing consistency,
and everyone freaked
out over that.
And I kind of knew
that they would,
because it's vanilla but cookie.
So I get you guys.
You know?
AUDIENCE: Is there a
flavor that surprised,
that sells as well as it
does, that you didn't expect?
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY: I
like things that are--
I like double-cookie.
So I guess I was pleasantly
surprised to see the tie-dye--
tie-dye is going strong.
Tie-dye has been our
most popular flavor
since we started the company.
And then, when
the book launched,
I created an electric
tie-dye, which is just
brighter-colored tie-dye.
And the two are neck-and-neck,
and every week I'm
sitting in the conference
room, and I look at the report,
and I'm like, yeah!
I root for electric tie-dye.
I don't know why.
I like the newer one, I like
the colors, it's super bright.
So that surprised me, because--
vanilla.
So I get it.
People like vanilla.
Who likes vanilla
here, over chocolate?
Who likes chocolate
over vanilla?
See, so it's surprising, right?
But it's also very
colorful, and I've
learned that people
eat with their eyes.
So in order for a flavor of
anything to be successful,
it has to be equally as
beautiful as delicious.
And it sounds like it's
not rocket science,
but when I look at other
products out there--
or when I go to a bakery,
or restaurant, whatever--
you really have to
sell with the way
it looks, and then the
taste is the other half.
OK.
So I stacked the cake.
Three layers is
what I recommend.
Otherwise, it gets
very difficult.
A spinny thing is super helpful.
And you see, it's
not super straight.
No promises, but because
you have the spinny thing,
it helps, because you
could spin it, and then--
I don't know.
It's crazy.
[LAUGHTER]
So there's this thing that
we refer to as a crumb coat.
This is the crumb coat.
So you do this thin
layer of icing around it.
You do a thin layer of
icing around the cake first,
and that just keeps
everything neat and together,
and then you go back
and you ice it again.
You're really supposed
to pop it in the fridge
and let the icing harden,
and then do another layer.
But I also like to
complicate things,
so I'm going to
put glaze on here.
And it's really pretty--
the little crumbs,
because they're colorful.
But you could just do a
crumb coat on a tie-dye cake
and leave it.
It looks like Funfetti.
So "Cakes by Melissa"
came out in October,
and I did all of this press,
and I work with my husband.
And we have this weird
competitive nature,
but it really works,
and that's how
we come up with such amazing
flavors for Baked by Melissa.
And I did a ton of live segments
like this, but for CNBC,
where you have a five-minute
segment and 30 seconds
to ice the cake.
And one night, we were lying in
bed, and he's like, you know,
when you do the
cakes on live TV,
you should probably
make them look
really symmetrical and nice.
[LAUGHTER]
I was like, you try doing that!
It's so hard.
So I'm going to try
and make this one
look really symmetrical
and nice for my husband.
And I'm going to
go home tonight,
and when we're lying in
bed, I'm going to tell him.
I appreciate all feedback.
I think it's super important.
See, look!
It's pretty nice so far, right?
You've just got to--
don't over-think it.
You're baking to enjoy.
That's why I bake.
That's why we're all here,
because I love to bake.
So when you're baking at
home, you should enjoy it.
And I associate Valentine's
Day with baked goods, because--
so if you don't want
to buy cupcakes--
which is totally cool.
I get it-- you should make
something and think of me.
[LAUGHTER]
No, but it's just fun.
I think you'll
have a great time.
Do it with your friends, or
whomever-- your kid, your--
OK.
So far, so good, right?
I think you're
actually technically--
I follow a lot of cake
makers on Instagram.
They usually start with the
top, and every time I watch one,
I'm like, oh, I should
start on the top.
And then I forget.
One question that people
ask me all the time is
how we started Baked
by Melissa, of course,
and what did you do differently?
All this stuff.
And I think one
thing that's super
important to anyone who wants
to be successful at anything--
can you see the prettiness of--
there's little specks
of the colors inside.
There's a certain
attitude that I
think is necessary for
success in anything,
especially in starting
your own business,
and it's a positive attitude.
And I know that sounds
crazy, but my attitude when
I was fired from my job--
so I was literally sitting
at this sink in my cubicle.
And I was called to
HR, and I thought
I was getting a promotion, and
I was fired, and I was so upset.
[LAUGHTER]
True.
I was so upset, guys.
Whatever, it doesn't matter.
But I was like
anyone who got fired.
I thought it wasn't my
fault, and I wanted to,
you know, whatever-- retaliate.
So I thought it was so unjust.
I went right to my
brother's office, crying,
and he said, go home
and start your business.
So go home, bake
your cupcakes, we'll
start a business out of it.
And it's not crazy,
because I love to bake.
And at the time, I--
[APPLAUSE]
Right?
It's pretty.
OK.
I don't have a lot of
time left, but I am
going to finish the story too.
But while I'm doing that,
I'm going to make glaze.
This is the best
part of this cake.
I take things too far.
If I mess something up,
I'll put glaze on it,
and it'll cover it up.
So I didn't mess
this one up, but I'm
going to put glaze on
it, because it's so fun.
And glaze is very complicated.
This is powdered sugar.
And I'm going to add whole
milk, and that's glaze.
I'm going to use a spoon.
OK.
So my brother is an
entrepreneur, a mad scientist
entrepreneur--
always had new business
ideas all the time.
And I love to bake,
and I always wanted
to go into business with him,
start a business with him.
So when he said, go home
and bake your cupcakes,
I was like, great.
It's a great idea,
because I'm really upset,
and I like to do that,
and it'll make me happy.
And at the time, I was
baking my tie-dye cupcakes--
I'm just going to move this--
for everyone and anyone.
If it was your birthday
and I loved you--
and I love a ton of people--
I baked you tie-dye cupcakes.
And the reason that I did that
was A, because I love to bake,
but B, because has anyone
ever baked something delicious
and given it to somebody?
It's the best feeling.
Truly, that's why I did it.
It was totally selfish.
I loved to bake for people
because it made me feel good,
and I did it all the time.
And I had been known
for my tie-dye cupcakes.
So when he said to do it,
I was like, great idea.
I baked four batches of
cupcakes the night I was fired.
My tie-dye, cookie dough,
s'mores, and peanut butter cup.
I would say those are my
four favorite flavors.
And I wound up sending them
into work with my best friend's
little sister, who was
interning at Alison Brod PR.
Anyone heard of
Alison Brod, maybe?
She was like a celebrity to me.
I'm not neat in the kitchen.
A female who started
her own business.
All women work there, whatever.
I hoped that she would
try the cupcakes herself,
but I didn't even know if
she went to work every day.
I just didn't know.
But in the back
of my mind, I was
hoping that Alison
would see the cupcakes,
and something
amazing would happen.
And would you know, that's
exactly what happened.
So I sent all these
cupcakes into work
with Carly, who was
interning there--
I'm out of breath again.
I'm sorry.
And Alison saw them.
She had her caterer in the
office, luckily, at the time.
And she was like, Ben,
look at these cupcakes.
They're amazing.
You should reach out to her.
So he did.
So I got a call from
Alison Brod's caterer.
The day after I was
fired from my job,
he wanted to bring me
into his office, which
was his apartment.
It was a little shady.
[LAUGHTER]
I went with it for a tasting.
So I ran back to my
brother's office,
and I was like, holy shit,
I just got to a tasting
with Alison Brod's caterer.
And he had his own business,
building websites for people,
so it was perfect.
I said, we have to
go, and they were
like, we have a
business already,
he could be a part of it.
I'm splitting it
up into two bowls,
and I'm going to dye each one.
Pink and blue, because those
are my favorite colors,
and because they look
beautiful when they combine.
So we were like, OK, we
need a name and a logo.
I wanted to go in there like
I had a business already,
and he could be a part of it.
Otherwise, what would
come from the opportunity?
That was my mindset.
And Brian and Matt were
totally cool with it.
Is there a spoon,
like a soup spoon?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY: Great.
A-ha.
Perfect.
Thank you.
So you don't need
complicated stuff.
So my brother's business partner
at the time for Muse Box,
which was the web
development company--
and it was literally just the
two of them in this little tiny
office on 38th and 8th--
was also our
childhood friend Matt.
So he knew me very well.
So my brother insisted that
the name of the company
had a personal tie, so we
liked Baked by Melissa.
I really wanted the
company to be called Baked,
but he insisted that
my name was in it,
which I'm so thankful about.
And Matt created the logo,
and it's the same exact logo
we had today.
I think I cried when I saw
it, because it's so perfect,
and it's so who I am and
who our brand is now.
And I mocked up bakery
boxes with our logo.
I got flat pastry boxes from
the Clover Deli on 34th and 2nd,
which was right across the
street from my apartment
at that time.
And I went to the
caterer for a tasting.
He loved the cupcakes, and I
did my first event with him less
than a week after I was fired.
We made business cards that
had my name, my home address,
and my cell phone number,
but they were also
branded Baked by Melissa,
so they looked so legit.
My parents were like,
what is happening?
People are just going to be
knocking on your apartment
door.
Literally, suite 27G.
I was apartment 27G.
And yeah, so people
came, and they
saw these unbelievable
bite-sized cupcakes
that were so beautiful
and also delicious.
Everyone knew cupcakes, but they
had never seen them bite-sized,
which was so cute.
And they would take
a cupcake, then
they would take a
business card, and then
you would go to
bakedbymelissa.com,
which Brian and Matt
obviously helped me create.
And we founded the
company together.
So the three of us
worked our butts off
to get to where we are today.
We shot the whole website
on my Ikea coffee table
with a white bed sheet between
the table and the cupcakes,
using my Canon
point-and-shoot camera.
And when people
saw the cupcakes,
they went to Baked
By Melissa, and you
could purchase 100 cupcakes
or more to be delivered by me,
from my apartment,
using the subway.
I would put a Baked by Melissa
sticker on a white pizza box.
And that's how we
started Baked by Melissa.
I did events, I
cold-called caterers,
I took advantage of every
opportunity that came my way.
OK.
Glaze time.
This is just really fun.
So I like tie-dye
and bright colors.
Therefore, the cake is going
to be very much like that.
So while we were
shooting the book,
I realized that if you alternate
colors of glaze, on a cake,
it makes a tie-dye effect.
And a beautiful shade of purple.
So that was 10 years
ago, which is crazy.
So since then, we've
opened 14 retail locations.
We ship our product
nationwide, so you
can send these to anyone.
bakedbymelissa.com.
Google love.
Can you see the top?
I just want to--
OK, anyway.
And then this is
an offset spatula.
This is a baby one.
Oh, it's so pretty.
It'll start to drip,
and you could totally
control all this stuff,
based on how much liquid you
put in the glaze.
If you want it to drip more,
then you put more liquid.
If you want to cover the whole
cake, you could do that too.
I just like to have fun with it.
Glaze dries really quickly,
so you have to move quick.
It's just so pretty.
OK, watch this.
Ready?
And you could make
it like tie-dye.
Yeah, it's fancy.
I'm very fancy.
There we go.
I guess I could probably
make it look prettier.
You know what?
I make little smudges.
But this is how I create things.
I just go with it, and
the end result is always
beautiful, no matter what.
Does anybody have any
questions for me, while I--?
AUDIENCE: How do you
mass-produce something
that seems so individualized?
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY:
That's so funny.
That's a great question.
So when the book came
out, my CEO and I,
who was probably my favorite
person in the world--
we were like, shit, are people
going to want to buy cakes now?
We just came out with a book
called "Cakes by Melissa."
Are they going to assume
that we sell cakes?
So we had to figure that out,
how to mass-produce cakes.
So what we do is we
make these sheets--
my husband does.
He makes all of these
sheets of tie-dye cake,
and then we have one
person who assembles them.
And I took a really long--
it's pretty quick.
We do sell a tie-dye
cake just like this
at bakedbymelissa.com.
You can pre-order it.
We say four days in advance, but
of course we make exceptions.
And wow, it's so pretty.
You can pre-order it, and
then pick-up is in-store only.
It's funny, because
Alison Brod has
been ordering a
ton of these cakes,
and I just love her so much.
I would do anything for her.
So I actually handwrite
"Happy Birthday"
to whomever she wants,
which we do not do,
but whatever Alison
wants, Alison gets.
So I do that for her.
And they're actually iced--
this cake is-- I did
this for the first time
when we were shooting the book.
I didn't plan.
I could have never told you
what this cake was going
to look like before I made it.
But the cake that I made while
we were shooting the book
inspired the cake
that we now sell,
and it's so beautiful, and
so delicious, and so moist.
It's very moist.
Sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
What do you guys
think about that word?
Do you think it's gross?
AUDIENCE: No, I'm OK with it.
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY: For
baking, it makes sense.
But we have conversations
about that word a lot
in my line of work, meaning
at Baked by Melissa.
We don't use it
in our marketing,
although I fight for it,
because it is, our product.
And then this is
my sprinkle blend.
And there.
There's my tie-dye cake.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: I believe we
have a few boxes of cupcakes
to give away for anybody
who has questions.
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY: Oh.
SPEAKER 1: And people
who asked already
can get one too, don't worry.
Can you pass the mic back there?
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY: Everyone
should just grab a fork
and take a bite.
That's what I would do,
but that's not appropriate.
It's like an arts-and-crafts
project that you can eat.
AUDIENCE: So did you
always make mini cupcakes?
Did you ever make larger ones?
Or what made you decide to
then do cupcakes specifically?
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY: I always
baked large cupcakes.
I really love cupcakes, so
I wanted to eat big ones.
But I also would eat two
large cupcakes a day,
and I knew that
if I was starting
a business with a product, it
had to be unique and different
in some way.
So we decided to
make it just a bite.
This way, you could
try every flavor
without the
post-dessert field trip,
and everything's
under 50 calories.
It's all real, the best
butter, sugar, Hershey's cocoa,
Hershey's chocolate, Chips
Ahoy cookies, Oreos--
but it's just 50 calories.
Less than that, because
it's just a bite.
It's perfect.
AUDIENCE: It's brilliant.
Yeah.
RIP Crumbs.
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY:
I love all cupcakes.
AUDIENCE: I have
a few questions,
but on that note of loving all
cupcakes, living in New York,
do you have any other--
besides your own-- any other
favorite stops around the city?
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY:
I love Sprinkles.
I do.
I love their strawberry cake.
I really just love it all.
I love all cupcakes.
I even like Crumbs' cupcakes.
There, I said it.
[LAUGHTER]
I used to get two Crumbs
cupcakes every day,
from the Clover Deli.
They didn't say
they were Crumbs,
but I know that
or they were made by
the same people who--
yeah.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Being a mom, working--
how do you do [INAUDIBLE] that?
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY: When
I first had my daughter--
so she's two now--
I was like, oh, you know, I just
work hard and do everything,
give my all, which is true.
I do, and it's hard.
So it's just really hard.
But I think it's important to
love what you do every day.
And I love going
home to my daughter,
but I also love working.
I don't think being
a stay-at-home mom
would be for me.
I'm tired a lot, being
pregnant and stuff,
but I'm really happy that I am
going to be an example for her.
Anyone can do anything,
and women can do anything,
and I'm happy to
embody that for her.
And it's hard.
AUDIENCE: Sure is.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So you said
you met your husband
on the first day of business?
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Tell us that story.
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY: Sure.
So it was opening day of our
very first retail location.
For those of you who
know the Soho area well,
the corner of Broadway
and Spring Street,
before it was NikeTown, was
a cafe called Cafe Bari.
And Cafe Bari had this
little pick-up window
that was attached
to it, and that
was our first retail
location-- a bite-sized--
if you will-- pick-up window
on Spring Street and the corner
of Broadway.
And it was part of Care Bari.
So opening day,
I'm freaking out,
thinking, who's going to
stop at this hole in the wall
and buy cupcakes they've
never heard of before?
I'm 24 years old, literally got
fired from my job seven months
prior, was just hustling
to bake cupcakes and try
and do what I love everyday.
And now we're opening a store.
So I was freaking out.
I didn't have the experience
or the confidence I have today.
I'm sitting at the bar.
We had gotten somebody to work
the booth for opening day,
so I could chill.
I had baked enough cupcakes.
It was the first moment I
was sitting down in months.
And David Z. was sitting
next to me at the bar,
and David Z. used to have
all these shoe stores named
David Z. throughout Manhattan.
His nephew was Ronnie Fieg, who
founded Kith, so that whole--
Ronnie used to work
for him, whatever.
And David was a
regular at Cafe Bari.
He came every morning
for his coffee,
and he was there that
morning for his coffee.
And he's like a charac--
he's like an old-- eh,
he's like my dad's age.
He is like a character.
He takes it too far
sometimes, though.
I had never met
him before, but I
knew who he was, because
he was well-known to me.
And he looks at the
bartender, who I had also
never met before,
and he says, Adi,
who is this beautiful girl?
And the bartender
looked me up and down,
and he said, that's my wife.
And I felt like he
was such a jerk,
but that's how I met my husband.
[LAUGHTER]
And he's Israeli, so
he would look at me
with these foreign
eyes, like I'm
the most beautiful girl in the
world, and it totally worked.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Please get the mike.
AUDIENCE: Do we have
time for another one?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY: Yeah,
I'm just washing my hands.
AUDIENCE: OK.
How did you guys come
up with the pricing
model for your products?
I know each of
these is a dollar.
I obviously buy your
product, and I spend that,
but some people say that's
too much, too little.
How did you price it all?
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY:
I'm telling you
it's definitely not
too much, because there
is so much that goes into every
single one of these cupcakes.
You know, our cupcakes
have been a dollar
since the day we started the
company, which is pretty crazy.
And I don't think as
much thought went into it
as you would
imagine, or probably
as we should have put into it.
But they're a dollar.
It's very clean.
I think it's nice
to be able to just--
hey, $3 for three cupcakes,
and that was our pricing model.
We started the company at
the end of the recession too,
so it was a time when people
weren't going and spending
a ton of money on things.
So for one dollar, you
could get something
that tastes delicious, brings
you back to your childhood
and makes you happy, instead
of going and buying jeans.
And yes, I am going to eat this.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Soo you have
an awesome success story.
But if you look back,
is there anything
you would have done
differently now, looking back?
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY: I would
have more confidence in myself,
probably, because
through my experience
I've learned that
you can do anything.
I can anything, you
could do anything.
It's a certain attitude,
and mindset, and work
ethic, and being
persistent and positive
and all that stuff that's
so cliche and totally true.
And I wish I knew that the way
I know that today, because maybe
I would have even--
now, if I set my
mind to something,
I know I'm going to
achieve it, which is nice.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you so much
for being here.
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
OK, so my question is, what
is your favorite memory with
[INAUDIBLE]?
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY: Oh.
I have so many.
We've been around for 10 years.
I took over Instagram
recently, in October,
during the launch of the book.
This was another "you
can do anything" thing.
Wrote the book in three
months, which was crazy,
but I really wanted it to
launch for holiday 2017,
because that's a great
opportunity for us to have
things to talk about
from a brand perspective.
And I told our CEO, I'm
going to take over Instagram.
And the only way the launch
of the book will be successful
is if I do that, and
I'm going to figure it
out and make it happen.
And he's like, you are.
I know you are now.
And I was very persistent
with the one person
who I knew there,
and I wound up taking
over Instagram's account,
which is 270 million followers.
I did an Instagram
story and a post
on the feed on
National Dessert Day.
And I'm not one
to say something's
going to happen
before it happens,
but we had gotten
confirmation, and we
created the concept beforehand,
and I was so excited.
So I told everybody,
and they said they
were going to post at 4:00.
They were on the other
side of the country,
and we were just waiting
and wasting time.
We were in Bloomingdale's
after an event.
It wasn't happening,
and I was freaking out.
And then I was on the
subway, underground,
going to another
event in Brooklyn.
And then we got out of
subway, and [INAUDIBLE]..
I could cry.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, it's so exciting.
And yeah, that's
what it's about.
We work so-- you, we--
we work so hard, so
enjoying those moments--
and that was a big moment--
but all the little moments too.
That's totally necessary.
SPEAKER 1: One more
question over there.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
When you were starting
up, did you ever
worry about
competition, and what
did you want Baked by
Melissa to be known for?
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY: You
give me so much credit.
[LAUGHTER]
All I knew is that
I had the chance
to do what I love every
day, which was bake cupcakes
and, in turn, eat them.
But-- focus.
I was focused on doing it.
I took advantage of every
opportunity that came my way.
If somebody wanted to try the
cupcakes, they got cupcakes.
I would go deliver
them, no matter--
I cold-called
catering companies.
All of my mind-power was
focused on doing everything
I could to do what
I love every day,
because I knew that if I
did it and it didn't happen,
then one day I would
look back and think,
"coulda, woulda,
shoulda," and I just
can't live my life that way.
So the rest of the
stuff, I didn't have time
to think about.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
SPEAKER 1: Yes, thank you
so much for coming in.
[APPLAUSE]
MELISSA BEN-ISHAY: Thank you.